OK, we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
A very good question here from someone thinking
ahead about voting in November.
Take a listen.
David.
Joe from California.
Yeah.
Hey, I've been seeing online people are suggesting
that they take their mail in ballot, their
absentee ballot to the polling place and dropping
it off.
Right.
Therefore, not having to put it on the post
office to have to mail and send it in.
Yep.
What do you think?
Good idea.
I think so.
I don't.
Yeah.
So.
So listen, the answer is it's probably a good
idea to go and drop off your ballot if you're
able to.
But what you have to understand is the post
office is a public service.
And there's a lot of people in this country
who don't have vehicles and can't easily get
to city hall or wherever you can drop off
your ballot.
There are people who live in really rural
areas.
So even if they have a car, they'd have to
take half a day off from work to go and drop
off their ballot, et cetera, et cetera.
So it really shouldn't depend on people going
and dropping off their ballot at City Hall
in person.
I plan to do it because Boston is small and
I can do it right.
I'll just find 20 minutes and I'll go over
and I will drop it off depending on where
you live.
You may be better off just mailing the ballot
early.
So, yes, it is a good idea to go and drop
off the ballot in person depending on your
circumstances where you have to drop it off.
How much you trust the mail system, where
you are and how early you're able to send
your ballot.
But certainly something people should consider.
On today's bonus show, we will talk about
North Korean Littlerock leader Kim Jong un
reportedly condemning pet ownership as decadence
and ordering dogs to be confiscated.
We're going to talk about the Texas governor
proposing freezing property tax revenue if
a city defunds police.
And we will talk about businesses that are
saying, you know, even if Trump does this
payroll tax thing, we're just not going to
do it.
We're not going to participate.
So a lot of important Mehdi.
Dories on today's bonus show.
And remember that August twenty third.
That's coming up.
August twenty third is the 15th anniversary
of the David Pakman show.
We will be having a single day membership
special, which you can be notified about by
signing up for our newsletter at David Pakman
dot com.
I'll see you on the bonus show.